How to build on agricultural land
to one thousand euros
a nice country house while saving
the constructible land?
All you have to do is take some agricultural land.
The construction should be as green as possible.
Before moving on to the construction stage,
there is 1 long journey of the fighter that can last
3 years.
The project must be well prepared.
The first thing,
is to choose 1 plot of land close to a construction
which will be less than 100m from your future house.
It is to facilitate the vrd.
Avoid isolated terrain,
the construction should be located
15m from a departmental road
preferably.
This is called 1 field
in the hollow of saw teeth.
These are lands that have the potential
to be constructible.
The main focus of this construction is market gardening
bio on small areas.
Find out in my next videos how
create 1 micro-farm,
statues and state aids.
Come on, bye bye,
bon taf